they say that Hollywood is a bulk
business and 2023 is not shaping up to
be an exception we're only halfway
through the year and there are already
some truly awful movies out there these
are the worst of the worst
the world is still trying to make sense
of the covid-19 pandemic one of the
purposes of Arts is to unpack the
emotions lessons and impact of shared
human experiences like this it's
unsurprising then that a curious
sub-genre of pandemic movies has
developed in recent years by and large
the somber anxious and surreal movies
have been met with Savage critical
assessments perhaps not enough time has
passed to gain an interesting artistic
perspective or maybe nobody wants to
relive the most painful days of 2020.
either way movies like lockdown and the
bubble were not well received and in
2023 life upside down joined them live
upside down consists of intertwining
stories about a few hard to root for Los
Angeles couples Art Gallery owner
Jonathan is stuck quarantining with his
wife but he misses his mistress Clarissa
who lives solo and interacts with the
world at a distance Sheltering at home
makes everyone sad mad and upset
feelings that audiences will certainly
remember experiencing themselves not
that long ago this did not land well no
minnow of Roger ebert.com had this to
say the characters are shallow and
tiresomely needy not to make any point
or learn any lessons just due to a lack
of imagination minnow is far from alone
in this opinion critics absolutely
lambasted the film released in 1990 the
original house party is a modern comedy
classic the lighthearted likable and
low-key Ensemble film star then popular
rap Duo kid in play as a couple of high
school friends who pull off an epic
rager despite numerous setbacks that
threatened to derail things at every
turn it spawned a couple of okay sequels
and in 2023 a remake the new film UPS
the stakes the wacky comedy and the
celebrity branding which results in an
incongruous jumble this time the
Partiers are adults best friends and
failed promoters Damon and Kevin about
to lose their low-paying jobs as house
cleaners and on the verge of financial
ruin they decide to throw a shindig in
the last house they're scheduled to
clean a mansion belonging to NBA
superstar LeBron James the rest of the
movie consists of materials celebrating
and lightly teasing James drug fuel
party hijinks and rapper cameos critics
didn't outright load the new house party
across the board but they were largely
unimpressed and confused as to why it
needed to exist as Richard Roper of the
Chicago Sun-Times put it the bash that
LeBron James's Mansion ends up feeling
more exhausting than exciting Brian
Richards of pajiba agreed writing this
version wasn't as funny or as good as it
could have and should have been and it
doesn't even have the same level of
Parts as the original
Reinventing the romantic comedy is a
noble and ambitious effort attempting to
explore a love story through the lens of
modern technology is even more enticing
millions of people spend their whole
lives on sophisticated smartphones but
it's hard to make staring at screens
smiling particularly romantic that's a
trouble with your place or mine a
Netflix original starring the usually
Charming Reese Witherspoon and Ashton
Kutcher both of whom have extensive
rom-com experience their character is
Debbie and Peter had a fling 20 years
ago they're now best friends who live on
opposite coasts after they get a taste
of each other's lives by switching
houses she goes to Los Angeles he
regroups in New York they wind up
falling in love almost the entirety of
their relationship unfolds via phone
calls your place or mine couldn't quite
overcome its own restrictions earning a
critical shellacking Rex Reed of the
Observer wrote about as romantic and
funny as a root canal is it safe
oh
others agreed calling the movie a flat
exercise in rom-comp trope's Cutting
Edge technology can't save in 1978
horror Master Stephen King published the
short story Children of the Corn in the
Anthology night shift before long
Hollywood adapted the creepy tale of a
tiny Midwestern Farm Town populated
entirely by sacrifice obsessed children
after making the first Children of the
Corn movie in 1984 the filmmakers never
stopped the latest Children of the Corn
is the 11th entry in the franchise this
time the story unfolds a little
differently the terrifying cult leader
is a 12 year old girl instead of a boy
and it's a Plucky high school student
who dares to stand up to her in her Army
of adult killing kids this latest take
on the story has additionally
differentiated Itself by earning truly X
workable reviews Richard Whitaker of the
Austin Chronicle said it's also
ridiculous and implausible Sarah
Michelle Fetters of movie Freak
concurred writing the only emotional
response as Children of the Corn scares
up is boredom a daringly Sinister
Slaughter of a sacred cow Winnie the
Pooh Blood and Honey boasts a simple
premise it's a horror version of A.A
milne's classic stories of the Hundred
Acre Wood famously populated by poo
piglet Tigger Eeyore and their human
friend Christopher Robin the work
entered the public domain in 2022 so
it's fair game for interpretation Winnie
the Pooh Blood and Honey doesn't do much
to analyze or satirize its well-known
Source material however the movie is a
buy the number slasher dressed in Pooh's
clothing and that novelty wears off
quickly the plot involves little more
than murderous incarnations of poo and
piglet attacking Christopher Robin and
several young women staying in a nearby
cabin Kyle Turner of the New York Times
laments is not funny enough to have
anything clever to say about its gag and
it's not exciting enough to be a
competent horror movie it's as if the
makers of paint set out to make a biopic
about big haired public television art
instructor Bob Ross but then couldn't
get the rights so they decided to make a
different movie about a guy who just
looks like Bob Ross paints written and
directed by Brit McAdams best known for
his work behind the camera on comedy
Central's Tosh.0 seems to want to make
fun of Bob Ross for no discernible
reason they're usually charming and
effortlessly funny Owen Wilson stars in
paints as Carl nargle he's a man very
satisfied with his life and appreciative
of it too Carl has everything an
enlightened man in the 1970s could want
like his own painting show on Vermont
Public TV adoring fans who paint along
with them at home and laudable hair he
then falls into an ugly but predictable
movie style existential crisis when
another younger better painter comes
along threatens his comfortable
existence and makes him confront some
ugly truths to compete in a crowded
Marketplace of special effects Laden
intricately plotted and would-be
Blockbusters action and sci-fi
filmmakers have to lay out as many new
ideas as possible but 65 written and
directed by Scott Beck and Brian Woods
the team responsible for the screenplay
for a quiet place when simple assembling
recognizable tropes from well-known
sci-fi properties the action begins on
the futuristic planet of samaris a pilot
named Mills volunteers for a two-year
space mission to get the money for the
miracle cure for his daughter's Illness
but he gets lost in space and crash
lands on an unfamiliar Planet along with
a child named KOA is no big surprise to
the audience when the planet turns out
to be Earth but it's 65 million years in
the past hence the generic title of the
movie do the two run for their lives
from giant dinosaurs and then also
falling space rocks of course they do
unfortunately the end result isn't any
fun and it doesn't feel particularly
inspired yeah but your scientists were
so preoccupied with whether or not they
could they didn't stop to think if they
should you've seen this movie before
with different names and different
characters on Rotten Tomatoes 65 cobbled
together and mediocre 35 critical score
Rex Reed of the Observer Savaged it
saying 65 is a gruesome thing to watch
even for dinosaur lovers and not much
fun either actors are supposed to be
performance chameleons disappearing into
the roles to tell a compelling story
ghosted Stars two actors so famous
radiant and associated with other roles
that it's nearly impossible to believe
them in this romance action comedy that
cribs from so many other movies Chris
Evans best known for his multiple
outings as Captain America
unconvincingly plays a regular guy named
Cole he goes on a date with a mysterious
and captivating woman named Sadie who's
so secretive that it's off-putting it's
almost as if she's a spy she is a spy of
course and as their young relationship
develops they fall into the midst of a
dangerous International keeper Sadie
sternly and violently bites the couple's
way out of trouble while Cole can't
believe the craziness around him even
after wild things keep happening every
five minutes as a result ghosted is
essentially a greatest hits collection
of familiar action movie tropes with a
26 rating on Rotten Tomatoes ghosted as
a frothy privilege that didn't leave a
good impression on critics when laima
wrote on australiasnews.com this was the
leftover scraps cobbled together from
better scripts Clarice Lowry of the
independent accused ghosted of trying to
brainwash his audience on accounts of
the lack of spark between the leads love
again is a movie out of its time and
Earnest but ultimately dull and dated
throwback to 90s romantic comedy movies
but it's got a little something extra in
the form of grief and sadness which the
film can't quite ever overcome that
makes for a totally weird movie Fled him
from Priyanka Chopra Jonas's Myra
mourning the death of her fiance to Myra
going on a wacky date with a doofus
played by Chopra Jonas's husband Nick
Jonas a prolonged wink to the presumably
in the no audience the block kicks off
with a heartbreaker of an inciting
incident Myra sends lovey-dovey text
messages to her deceased fiance's old
phone number unaware it's been given to
rob a journalist who just so happens to
be an attractive man roughly Myra's age
at the moment he's spending an
inordinately long time profiling Celine
Dion presented as a contemporary
Megastar as you might guess based on
that bit of info Love Again leans hard
into the 90s Vibes Celine believes in
love and so she plays Cupid for Robin
Myra
are you okay I'm fine I just uh
threw up in my mouth a little bit a 24
score makes love again a Rotten Tomatoes
dud with critics decidedly not Charmed
by the movie David Ehrlich of Indie wire
bemoaned most of the lap lines in Love
Again are stale enough that even just
hearing them kind of hurts your teeth at
least two critics had pretty much the
same complaints with Mara Eakin and the
Chicago Reader saying she didn't enjoy
the movie's Hallmark level plot and Rex
Reed of the Observer negatively
comparing the whole thing to a Hallmark
card